[Musik]
afrika und falls ihr euch fragt warum
ich eine sonnenbrille auf habe ich bin
einfach relativ cool nicht auch eine
damen und herren de und ich werde dann
legen nebel fahren ins stadion weil der
erste fc köln heute spielt endlich habe
ich auch mal bälle
hier sind es bereitet mir meine damen
und herren ich rede heute über einen
zorn des ist es mir ein pickel ausdrücke
also sowas summarum look zeigen
ich wollte ein bisschen über musik reden
und so weiter und so fort weil ich aus
habe mittlerweile seit einem jahr aktiv
bin dort mixtapes hochlage und bewahrte
das müsste übrigens den tunnel ich habe
vor ein paar tagen eine ein euro
challenge gemacht hat ich mir an mich
gedacht und in diesem video haben wir
uns gegenseitig produkte in diesem
tv-abend gekauft wo wir dachten dass sie
für den anderen cool sind das die
anderen personen sicherheit darüber
freuen würde ich habe ich jude dann ein
mister und misses schild geschenkt die
fans allerdings überhaupt nicht gut da
haben wir unsere single freundin carola
geschenkt und haben das geführte shop
wie sie mit sich selbst herum kuschel
allerdings spielt köln in 30 minuten
wir haben nicht mal ein ticket und
müssen da jetzt auch erstmal noch zum
stadion fahren die sagen kommen hier im
stadion freuen damit die scheiße des
branchen ich mit einigen deswegen lieber
draußen worden wäre
die beschissenen plätze ganz unterm dach
[Applaus]
wie das vorbei freunde köln hat bereits
zu 1 gewonnen das heißt sie sind jetzt
tabellenführer
wir sind wieder zu hause angekommen
freude das spiel war echt richtig krass
ich zeig euch mal wie sc abgelaufen ist
also dieser ball hier ist der erste fc
köln diese flasche hier ist auch das
fußballspiel ca so ab komplette rasur
tabellenführer fc hier irgendwo ganz
ganz ganz weit weg in der liga
allerdings soll der ganze block
natürlich nicht nur vom fußballspiel
handel sondern ihr seht es bereits den
titel eingeblendet mein eigener storm
kurze entwarnung ich werde nicht
anfangen zu singen allerdings lade ich
nun seit mehr als einem jahr schon
mixtapes wo ich irgendwelche idm tracks
oder dance muss die techno future aus
zusammenmixen in diesem kanal um 10 20
minuten kompletten mix die lade ich seit
einiger zeit schon bei sound hoch jemand
kurzer ausschnitt
und das ist halt auch sonntag ich habe
750 tausend follower und meine mix haben
hier immer so 350.000 290.000 260.000
290.000 344.000 jahren immer unfassbar
viele plates und unfassbar viele
kommentare aus italien und belgien und
so leuten die halt wirklich mich
überhaupt nicht kennen nicht wissen was
ich auf youtube machen nicht wissen was
ich bin schwach instagram hochladen
übrigens instagram laser könnte werde
ich auch mal vor wie feiern einfach nur
die mucke die ich quasi mache und das
ist auch an alle die davon die wetter
ist gar nicht so viel ahnung haben ich
mache diese lieder nicht selbst also ich
produziere nicht sondern ich nehme
vorhandene liedermacher irgendwelche
remix ist daraus mashups und schneidet
die einfach zusammen beziehungsweise
denke ich hiermit meinen equipment läge
das passe auf und macht dann aus 15
songs die ich feiere einfach einen
riesigen mix deren zehn minuten lang
geht wo die ganzen songs mit drin sind
die ganzen drops und ich bin aktivität
tatsächlich beim autofahren gekommen und
zwar bin ich autobahn gefahren und ich
hatte mal mega abgefragt was wir irgend
welchen house und techno die dann sich
das erst zwei minuten aufbaut bis der
richtige job kommt und ich dachte mir
das system ist ein schneller gehen ich
will dass die ganze zeit drops kommen
deswegen bin ich halt auf die idee
gekommen das ganze einfach mal zusammen
zunächst hatte das zu beginn hatte ich
mit premiere gemacht also ein programm
was eigentlich primär für videoschnitt
geeignet ist ich konnte das tempo und
ich richtig anpassen also komplett mit
bpm es ging gar nicht irgendwie dann
habe ich 128 lied mit einem 118 air
liquide übergang gemacht hat das hat er
sich richtig scheiße an und dann habe
ich mir gesagt hey luca du musst dir
irgendwie so ein controller kaufen muss
dem mischpult kaufen muss ganz indien
bisschen professioneller angehen
er hat das lange zeit nur für mich
selbst gemacht und immer eine story
gehauen auf instagram und so dafür da
meinten als relativ viele leute
tatsächlich luca was ist das nur musik
die leute haben wir halt geschrieben
dialog hat sie sind nach veröffentlichen
sich echt cool an und wollte das aber
die auf youtube machen weil ich
eigentlich dachte das ist echt scheiße
ist und ich bin auch echt ein profiteur
drin deswegen habe ich seit auf
soundcloud hochgeladen und da haben
nicht jetzt mittlerweile beim elften
oder zwölften mixtape und habe insgesamt
in dieser 11 12 mixtapes jetzt schon ich
würde sagen so 30 stunden arbeit
gesteckt und bisher 0
euro da hat verdient wenn man aufs auto
halt einfach nichts verdienen sind es
ganze ist eine eigenschaft projekt von
mir und um jetzt aus thema zu sprechen
zu kommen ein eigener song ich möchte
nicht mein leben lang nur lieder
zusammen mixen die andere leute gemacht
haben sondern ich möchte natürlich auch
selber eventuell mal einen track machen
und produzieren
cool oder ich bin super cool juli wie
findest du das
dass ich in den raum ein eigenes lied
machen möchte und live wie findest du
das graphit tanzt schon
ja das stimmt das lied muss schon gut
werden
fluffy ist auf jeden fall motiviert dazu
im club abzugeben glaube ich jetzt
überhaupt nicht vorstellen können was
ich überhaupt damit meine einen eigenen
track zu machen es sollte nicht diese
standard youtuber musik werden web mäßig
oder irgendwas von katja oder so ist
aber nicht so werden wie das was derzeit
die ganzen deutschen rapper machen
nämlich einfach jede woche irgendein
trick raus hauen wo quasi keine richtige
mühe so wirklich drin steckt sondern
einfach nur raus geballert wird weil man
an stream zeit so viel verdient in
letzter zeit sehr gute perspektive
bekommen sondern ich will mir halt
wirklich mühe geben damit und ich will
die tägliche menge geld in die
auch ein cooles musikvideo auf die beine
zu kriegen und ich stelle das einfach so
vor wie beispielsweise das was für die
szenen beispielsweise das finde ich mega
cool oder machen
das sind selber musiker die nicht selber
singen sondern quasi das lied
produzieren den track machen und das
ganze abmischen fdp und singen tut
anhalt ging wirklich professioneller
sänger und ja keine ahnung ich will auch
eigentlich gar nicht zu lang und zu viel
darüber reden sondern mit liegt dieses
thema etwas seit langer zeit aus dem
herzen und ich wollte schon immer mal
sagen würde dir den ganzen meine chance
geben also hättet ihr baut darauf dass
ich mal probieren mit einem sänger oder
sängerinnen elektronisches lied machen
keinen bock drauf tasten leicht
verwenden jahren irgendwie was bisher
von langweilig dieser blog muss auch
irgendwas cooles machen port royal mit
luca ich möchte der beste spieler
wirklich viele leute haben mir die
kommentare geschrieben halo kwadrat mal
wieder vorn ein hoch du bist ja so gut
da drin
ich hab halt keine gegner so das ist ein
bisschen das problem aber ich würde
sagen wir lassen ja erstmal lady links
ist vielleicht auch ganz gut dass ich
jetzt nicht so das komplette video nur
über diese musik sache rede haben da
werde ich gleich noch mal kurz darauf
eingehen aber wir wollen natürlich
erstmal bisschen holz r falls ihr
übrigens irgendwelche papageien im
hintergrund hört juli schaut sich videos
an die papageien mit alexa sprechen ua
freunde da drin ist eine waffe hey
schönen guten morgen pumpgun so weigert
ich war noch nicht bereit meine
platzierung ist 69
das zu meinem namen neue runde neues
glück stellt euch mal vor man fliegt in
urlaub und so weiter und so fort und
dann kann man einfach irgendwo mit dem
regenschirm rausspringen aus dem flieger
soll dann bräuchten wir müssten ja
einfach irgendwelche rundflüge anbieten
gibt es ja was hinter dem wasserfall
da kann ich mich duschen hier ne dieser
windows pcs nicht mit der letzte runde
diese nur da ist er nicht genug ich ach
du scheiße da bin ich gerade noch so
rausgekommen dass man eigentlich zu
spawnen insel dahinten fliegen geht
nicht ist trauriger ist halt dass ich
jetzt in dieser runde vier plätze besser
war als vorhin meine letzte runde
brauche noch machen wir hier enthielt
mal ein bisschen action erstmal bräuche
waffe das ist natürlich das a und o in
solchen runden hat uns einer direkt die
tür wenn die türen offen sind wir doch
schon jemand drin alles raus ja oh mein
gott ich bin froh weil ich mit meinem
das a und o bei vorteil meine lieben
freunde ist dass man sich leise
fortbewegt ich mache jetzt mal hier so
ein kleines guckloch um zu sehen ob da
draußen war jetzt kann sich jeder sehen
wo sind denn die gegner habe ich den
ganzen tag zeit ich um ein holz
hahaha herzlichen glückwünsche + + 29 so
wurde ich diesmal ich habe hunger
wir gehen jetzt ich hätte gerne einmal
alle eigentlich wollten wir das essen
mit nach hause und halt zu hause essen
aber justin und weg dort sind gerade
hier um die ecke und da sagen wir kurz
hallo
anhänger der hessen jetzt einfach hier
ich bin zu dieser viktor schwarz war
heute einfach lieben es hat jetzt wieder
zu hause angekommen meine damen und
herren findet der logen paul gegen casey
boxkampf statt was ist das wtf alter
jagger war so eine maske die bahn auf
das denkt wer gewinnt heute und direkt
paul blutet aber schon leute die beiden
hier kämpfen einfach so hoch wie diese
mädels dass man die ganzen schweiz mit
vision kein bisschen was ganz schön hin
café rheinblick wer hängen mein kampf
ziehen der rest also bisher ist es
wirklich so dass beide irgendwie völlig
am arsch sind aber ich glaube immer noch
dass justin das ganze gewinnt
wakeboarder geboren leute hab das
gedacht dann 36 jahre alt und suche die
frau fürs leben hat eine maske auf die
theologen paul das internet übelste
maschine freunde sowie justin case
veranstaltet einfach sonne regen kann
slogan gerade schon ein bisschen ab
gegen den regen das unentschieden
dann kann das vorbei freude ist wirklich
ein unentschieden zwischen karzai und
logan bailly hat gewonnen gegen rhji ich
glaube das werden alle ca damit machst
du gerade ein kung-fu-tritt ich bin
nicht im irrenhaus ich glaube jeder der
fit bekommen auf jeden fall wollte ich
ja noch mal ganz kurz über den titel
reden die leute ich bin ganz ehrlich ich
habe noch nicht angefangen irgendwie
anderem songs zu arbeiten aber dieser
gedanke schon die ganze zeit in meinem
kopf und ich möchte nicht anfangen damit
das irgendwie zu machen und nicht mit an
den song run zu setzen ohne dass ich
überhaupt darüber geredet habe und dass
irgendjemand denkt der ist jetzt
youtuber der muss jetzt auch ins haus
bringen und geld machen und was ich
gemacht wirklich wie gesagt einfach
unfassbar viel spaß hier irgendwie
schwachsinn zu machen mut zu machen hier
irgendwie ab und zu mal was irgendwie in
logic um zu spielen und ja also weil
halt viele leute meinten ja doch mal nix
ist auf youtube hoch das geht halt nicht
so gut wegen der ganze rechte sache also
ich mixe halt vorhanden der lieder
remixes zusammen deswegen wenn ich das
auf youtube hochladen fick mich halt
voll kanal von geparde haben auch
übrigens sender ist victor und lasst uns
einfach ihren regenschirm vergessen es
hat einfach drei mal geregnet heute
allerdings würde ich an der stelle der
heutigen blog jetzt auffällt
meine schulter dreckig und aus dem
jordans krieg ich dass sie von mir aus
gerne mal ein leichter schaffen 14 tage
kommt auf jeden fall auch ein neuer mix
auf soundcloud also das ist auf jeden
fall in der beschreibung und verlinkt
ich wollte einfach etwas musik thema
besprechen weil ich mich da jetzt ein
bisschen weiter bilden wollte und ich
will euch natürlich auch auf neuesten
stand halten was bei mir so abgeht und
ich bin dumm und hässlich und dumm
[Musik]